il y en a pas d'anniversaire y un
adversaire des missiles
ont supprimé notre super soirée pour sa
foi mais non c'était très bien oui
les 35 ans m6
met à tourner puisque j'ai mis tous les
animateurs qui ont jalonné l'histoire
des messages mais c'était pas menacer
hausse moi je voulais pas en parler n'y
a
pas plus que ça si vous n'étiez pas
bougé pas été invités j'ai vu que vous
étiez un petit peu énervé sur les
réseaux sur leur neige et fernand vallet
qui souhaiteraient sympathique cérémonie
non non non non si son nom non voilà un
anniversaire je ne vous oublierai jamais
vous vous immuable
il a bien fait ses preuves non mais
parce que et comment ça c'est qu'ils
vous ont pas invité et puis je pense
qu'il s'agit je pense qu'ils ne m'aiment
pas oui si plus alors il vous adore psy
à la cimade or il m'invite pas eu un
problème non mais c'est pas moi ya plein
de gens qui l'adorent il les invite
jamais la maison non je sais pas je
pense que on s'est séparés un peu
brutalement je pense qu'il ya encore un
peu de rose santiso en
tête ils ont oublié en fait j'ai pas
fait ces démissions qui ont marché sur
la chaîne
alors jeune a plaisir à benjamin sachez
que nous avons contacté le directeur des
programmes de m6 ça et nous avons réussi
à l'intégrer au programme de la chaîne
10 de la semaine prochaine regardez le
l'un des benjamins sera dans quatre fois
mariée au premier regard
[Applaudissements]
ce soir dimanche soir benjamin sera dans
un internat mais vous il sera sous titré
c'est toujours p début d'émission se
tient et une nouvelle émission et à
venir sur un avis puisque dominique
chapatte a lancé une version inédite de
turbo qui s'appelle tueur bulls
mais benjamin vous inquiétez pas à mon
avis vous n'êtes pas invités parce que
je pense que je pense que j'en ai
mémoire non pas du tout vous avez vous
avez dit du mal qu'un animateur de m6
non je ne crois pas d'une émission tête
a dit oui je
déteste ça peut-être c'est peut-être est
super je suis pas fan de l'été ce non
plus mais mon avis mon amour
c'est pas la raison c'est quoi la raison
oui on peut le dire
il animait nouvelle star c'était un
carton c'est vrai il s'est barré à la
moitié de l'émission tu dis
que tu la connais pas et ben oui mais
prem's et que tu oublies beaucoup de
choses il s'est barré à la moitié pour
aller à tf1 tf1 le dit c'est compliqué
une rupture de contrat le m perez qui
est un génie a dit si on passe d'un jama
castaldi de cdd à cdi ça va permettre de
faire un contrat et tout va passer et
donc tf1 lui a fait un cdi il s'est
barré à la moitié c'est bien gêné efira
qui a récupéré nouvelle star à la moitié
rap et tavernost avait dit si karim je
lui pardonnerai jamais est-ce que c'est
pas les squares jeu c'est vrai tu dis
des bêtises tu es mal informés dit la
mairie non non c'est pas ça du tout je
t'explique effectivement tels que des
choses vraies comme d'habitude tu prends
des boues qui font vrai tu fais une
grosse merde au tour donc la vérité
c'est quoi j'avais aimé vous unit c'est
un ami
j'avais effectivement un cdd balle en
fête le cdd il fallait le rompre à une
certaine date pour pas qu'il se
renouvelle j'étais en négociation avec
tf1 vous avez quand même planté m6 ne
voit la raison mais je veux finir mon
histoire
milieu d'émission pour signer un cdi et
minéraux pas
à bernon à dire un jour a dit ne jamais
vous avez fini la nouvelle star ou pas
non mais alors pourquoi payer efira
pourquoi je n'ai pas fini parce que
quand effectivement c'est dû dénoncer
mon cdd j'ai demande à tes seins ici la
vérité
il a very décision je la verrais 3%
alors j'ai tout avec s'est pas arrêté de
me battre a dit abel et et
résa la chaîne n'a jamais vu ça moi j'ai
eu quelqu'un qui m'a dit on n'a jamais
vu ça de ville a envoyé un huissier il a
réveillé la chaîne à dimanche à 8h du
matin 8 heures du matin ils ont appelé
le grand patron ils en sont pas encore
remis vrai ou pas castaldi faux pas
comme ça donc confiné aux histoires rien
de lui si un biberon à lantin c'est
louche tout ça
je m'explique en quoi ce mec c'est tuer
vas-y alors quoi c'était mon club et si
la parole est à la défense
elle dit je me fous de vos deux vous
avez aux uns et aux autres la vérité
c'est la suivante c'est que devait co je
vais rompent le cdd ce pas une date ce
que tu peux te prendre
verront passer d'aidé en date du 23 je
crois de mémoire et pour le 23 points à
barack obama marche ou avril français il
est bon il fallait qu'il fallait que
donc je donne mon congé avant le 23
comme on négocie en parallèle avec tes
fins que vous avez donc déjà fait vous
aussi négocier en parallèle moi oui oui
j'ai déjà dit ça peut arriver sage est
arrivé malade ne fait pas le malin vous
avez déchaussement voulait dire mais
pour l'instant ça ne s'était donc
l'effectif
effectivement j'ai déjà dénoncé ce
contrat le 23 mai c'était pour signer un
cdd qui commençait un cdi qui commençait
à la fin de saison et quand m6 très vexé
très logiquement il avait raison hu a
appris que je quittais la chaîne taverne
home a débranché au lac simon amis qui
boivent plus que j'adore aussi jean juan
mythomane
tu veux ce calme toi j'ai horreur qu'on
que les geeks ont initié alors parle de
l'huissier était à l'écouté des génisses
fait abrutis ou pas partant de levergies
défiera jaussen non c'est vrai
sous sa direction mais du coup ils
cesser viennent donc laissé filer en
pleine saison il est bien sûr que
j'allais se disent on aurait pu deviner
conneries je fais virer tf1 tu as appelé
pour trois tonnes taverne otani fini la
saison et roland perez et a dit
effectivement le bon moyen c'est d'avoir
un cdi ça te permet de casser ton cdd et
de verser des bourses heures avant oui
mais je dis pas qu'on a raté pareille
jusque tabernaux qu est l homme de coeur
et qui avait dit je les fais démarré sur
le love story c'était personnes et a dit
un jour à un dîner par hasard que
j'étais avec du monde a dit un dîner je
lui pardonnerai jamais et en effet il
n'a jamais pardonné et va très bien et
tu leur a gâché leur anniversaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]